all right yeah hello I'm not Sam
I said I'm definitely not Sam I'm just
taking her place we're like 15 20
minutes to get you guys started we had a
little me and her had a little
miscommunication
I thought she thought 11:30 I thought
I'd hold her lemon it's all good though
she's gonna be here soon so thank you
guys all for tuning in there's a new
Lunar New Year event I actually had no
idea yesterday I was just yesterday I
was more stoked that there was like the
ability to change skins like before your
game and I was like dude that's sick
it's gonna be so nice when we stream
tomorrow oh yeah exactly and then I was
like that's what we're gonna shooting
tomorrow changing your skin before you
play a match oh wait turns out you're
the dog as you can see on the screen
right now there are a bunch of new scans
Mercy's got anyone saria's got anyone
some pretty dope one why don't you go in
there the hero gallery like we always do
Joey yeah we know then we can look at
the rest I can't even say that pretty
good I think her gun looks cool yeah her
gun looks all right I think I had the
dog at the bottom there like on the on
the circle a dog yeah oh yeah I don't
know or dragon that dragon maybe you're
the dog just feathers on the mm on the
end of that all right your staff and
then the gun pretty pretty pretty
Austrian that's fine though that's not
the important part let's be real here
all right what else we got Faro all
right so these ones are pretty
these are back to the event prices 3,000
yeah it sound like these like her helmet
a lot it's uh would you say that's a dog
or a dragon weird like everything looks
more like a dragon than a dog and we're
not in the year of the dragon I know
oh yeah like that reminds me of like in
Mulan when they were
dragon heads on them oh my god I
actually will probably get this one well
we bought boxes as usual just so you
guys know thank you guys all for tuning
in
we're live or day at 11:00 playing
various games sometimes overwatch events
sometimes you know fortnight pup G
monster hunters weekly with John Luke
and Ben so you know if you haven't
subbed your liked please do that and
then also we'll be checking out chat so
if you have questions or that's the gold
version yeah okay okay well I'll turn
the gold off for a second so you can
every time you trick me okay every time
you get me with the damn like I'm
thinking you know going - joy looks good
sorry guys got a good skin oh it's even
like rotating on there okay so like
different zodiac yes it clearly doesn't
matter that it's year the dog we know we
don't theme around the actual lunar um
the zodiac here but you know whatever
that Genji is sick the Genji is sick
like I don't even play Genji and maybe I
have to buy the running joke was that it
was gonna be white ranger like a tiger
white ranger but you just go down the
list oh I like the globe and then the
mask is like awesome just everything
about that reminds me of a monster
hunter armors yeah I mean longsword oh
my god but oh yeah let's take a look at
the sword okay there's a shuriken it's
pretty pretty whatever you know you
can't you can't do too much there but
yeah yeah man it's good stuff man why
they keep doing this to us what do you
mean you use make this one to others a
widow as well oh yeah yeah they show
thank you
can't say your name also if there's
other skins that you guys know about
that we don't know about
please tell us so that we can check them
out okay so like kind of like a like a
like was it what do you call those that
the Chinese the Oh God as a guy it's
like the you know like when you change
into the red one yeah
like that in a way but not probably
could those repeat later yet widow was
kind of hurting for like a nice skin for
a long time like her last one I think
was oh no she has the blizzard world one
where is it
Nova hey that's a good one yeah that's a
good one but I mean like yeah yeah I'm
sure it's definitely not a kimono get
your back straight this is come on okay
so art there's gotta be like legendary
skins right these are the legendary I'm
sorry uh epic skin yeah it's gotta be I
feel like there's got every fashion and
McCree I don't know just people are
saying chat stuff and I'm I'm getting oh
wait yeah that's rooster that's the same
one that's last year yeah yeah oh just
looking for the icon wait so what is the
the you're the dog I can't look like no
it's the same thing all right let's try
to find them then I guess so nothing
that's the same one from last yeah
that's a good one denied one from last
year okay let's go down the list see who
did not have one so you're basing it off
of that yeah I guess that makes sense
right you probably wouldn't get a dupe
or like another new one junk rat had one
last year and I never I never got this
that's a good one if you get it this
year bargain a bargain basket right
there
as the Chinese firecrackers and why not
from him they had one last year right
yeah McCrea oh here we go oh
the magistrate's oh my god
ah that's pretty dope I like it I like
it
like his gun it also changes his facial
hair a little bit
oh he's got the mustache go yeah alright
yeah no it's just place it's just a pipe
it was like longer I guess around the
front where it's usually like poignant
yeah it's like slightly different okay
it's got a fuller mustache ooh that's
the nice gun though yeah
now blunderbuss but I was thinking that
though in my head I was like yeah with
like though we did look at doing fists
he had nothing our probably probably
that's why why like a pipe you got yeah
that's nice
I don't know though I know do you feel
legendary they're a little epic to me I
mean it's only because it's like very
telling me it's done yeah she's like
sorry Azure or Ganges but it like it is
a full redesign of his of his armor I
think it's cool
bear you the voice of reason all right
Mei had one last year so I'm guessing
his fire oh she has two there's one
color zero yeah same one we know mercy
had one no more hasn't really gotten a
new one in a while huh I don't think
she's gotten any when she can yeah
Orissa people were saying okay
people were saying okay a food dog for
Orissa I think it's possible and I have
been right no no no no try disappointed
we know far I had one for the new one as
you guys saw nothing for our boy Rapide
EBEs on my boy reap okay so him what's
this one oh it's a shock yeah so this is
from last year yeah so Reinhart Road
hogs Zinio and who's the last one cousin
yes dad the fourth like Wukong the whole
wakhan clans does not turn Sam that's
what it is
shrinks I'm pretty sure that's what it
is in Chinese Chung Somme I think [ __ ]
I'm not sure I think it's right though
trees are had one last you wince didn't
have one yeah I was looking at Torbjorn
and thinking Winston God so he's the
last one that I guess could have won
nope now that's kind of funny that they
the only one that they don't show in the
splash screen is McCree because they
show I'll show ya all the other ones
like Zarya yeah that's true maybe she's
got another one doubt it no that was
last year yeah that's a pretty simple
one those patients are going to get mad
at him no they're not I'm not the female
I'm not a I'm not when you get married
and if you are gonna do the
changing of the dress mid reception
dinner that's for the female to deal
with not as the male I said I still wear
the same suit or tux the whole time so
it's like what do I do now you want to
try the new so there's new capture the
flag or not new capture the flag what
they like kind of balanced it better and
there's a new map too right yeah so
we'll definitely be checking that out
and then also we have 51 loop boxes that
we're gonna open and hopefully he
doesn't get screwed over like he did
laughs I'll open my free or one free one
yeah okay there's a new emote for Road
hogs is 200 it's like your friend that
you mentioned where is like free mercy
off the free box it's only because no
because nobody's playing her now so
let's just give it to him yeah I guess
that's true huh she did get nerfed to be
I mean I kind of liked that just because
I like seeing Moira and like a little
bit I guess that's just the swings you
have to endure your different metals
sure I'm good over so dragon dance all
right all right let's fine just keep
going maybe you maybe go 2500 mile it's
not okay it just looked the same another
just give me all the mercy skins right
now they're like there's not enough
mercy players we really need to make you
want to play mercy and to legendaries
back to back
we'll check highlight heroes and modes
in a second oh good got equip no more
risk in primary succession sorry yeah
Gold and then that's a I think that one
yeah
show Kenji please we actually Oh Oh
McCree what are you yeah this is the
dream this is this is a green floor
boxes this is I guess making up for the
blizzard world one word man you got you
got one all right we got that magistrate
as well watch the the Highlander later
with it oh you got the combo right yeah
the Makri combo all right now we're
following back to earth here yeah we
need some YC baby this is Ryan Hart with
I don't know who was on his shoulders
doing though did you ever do I I ever do
it myself
yeah okay so I'd never I've never done
like lying dancing but multiple times I
have done the Dragon Giorno Chinese
there in the Chinese New Year great the
really big dragon yeah I've done that a
couple times through Chinatown which is
pretty fun it actually is pretty tiring
yeah so that's why we had a lot of
people just running and swapping in it's
just a lot of up/down or like you follow
Oh spud get the oh here I'll go full
camera okay to hide you're like um I do
this right I like exit the desktop and
then go back in because of the turns
what happens on the day of an event
everyone comes back oh it's a main
little lie the library news take a few
minutes boom now now we're going back in
you may need to restart your game client
is what it is
okay well tries first I would assume
this is also hitting console because
this the skin changing thing was for
sure gonna hit consoles so I assume that
this event would also hit console at the
same time now I don't know if it's out
exactly yet for ps4 Xbox one but you
guys in chat can tell me if you guys
know yet but I would assume if it's not
out it will be soon we are getting back
in the game hopefully no queue here
hopefully we will play oh we don't yeah
maybe there's an okay I'm going to close
it hard yeah let me see if heads up has
a like a lunar show year like a looser
new year version yeah I might have to
buy it again $4.99
so download all the packages yet right
oh no we couldn't find what you want
what we wanted to show you that's
wonderful
I'm gonna launch this I okay my heads-up
is straight crashing which is not good
all right keep closing that game server
oh you know what it is no no it's my
it's my lack of Wi-Fi I think although
why would it need Wi-Fi to play this
game okay we're entering we're entering
ooh I'm also entering heads-up
crap Rob just messaged me something
probably important all right football oh
I can do football probably Oh an
unexpected server occurred server is
live on Xbox one says Joe's awesome it's
out on ps4 right now 1.2 a 2 gigabyte
update thanks Marcus lone wolf do I need
to back out again oh yeah let's do that
sorry guys we are trying in the meantime
I'm trying to find a Lunar New Year
heads up game as we stall to get into
the game but or blizzard was like dude
we just gave you too many Legendary's my
nose broke the algorithm no more for you
sir yes server problems currently a part
of it is I feel like every time they
launch an event or at least more
recently it seems to get multiple like
tiny patches
yeah like in like the first like 10 that
like as they launches they're like okay
we have to do live maintenance yeah
exactly must be doing that they they've
done that like I think I was at least
two times last time it took us we got in
we were able to do some stuff then we
got kicked out for a bit and then
eventually it like stabilized so it's
almost better if we did start at 11:30
sorry Sam you were probably right you're
high you know I might not have gotten
these nice skins that's true that our
energy would have been off oh god no I
don't know is it trying to take your
picture it wants to record audio - no no
no here we go so it's always this
football football wait I thought we were
doing there is no Chinese New Year stuff
okay um this is pass oh we're in we're
in forget it I would never have gotten a
Texas A&M
oh that's really hard actually like how
do I even how do I even get you to see
that without seeing
Aggies or Texas A&M yeah I don't know I
don't know how you do that you probably
have to name a college football player
of which I wouldn't know who they are so
anyways we are just straight going for
it just go don't even we can't was this
in the last one I know there's a bow
okay nice okay
do try again on literally and yeah we're
into goop don't worry we got some sprays
yeah we don't need we how lucky for you
that mercy is not good anymore okay
you're hearing a lot of New Year stuff
though I know surprisingly they I mean
it favors it right that like it's
supposed to quit there's actually like a
themed loot box it'll more than likely
will give you that's not new Johan
doesn't know prime or age yeah more than
likely give you something from that and
whereas Blizzard world was just talk
about mercy what if why didn't he have
that I know was that like one of those
they're like huh what do you think about
this is like too ridiculous for it to be
engaging awesome that's all suck so
tracers pumpkin victory pose man that
would have been sick I know I feel like
he said something like that movies real
good Lamborghini mercy
all right more gold yeah this is true
soldier preach it respect your elders
yeah what's up I don't know if I can say
your name mr. Lai there we go
oh we got a lily widow skin awesome yeah
I have to say though Kenji Kenji Zarya
right top - yeah 100% talk to you for
the the skins this time macri's a
sleeper hit this sleeper so much that he
wasn't in the splash intro screen like
see how is that in you I don't know he's
yo please oh oh these new it isn't you
who is he doing something Napoli's maybe
35 to go feeling good oh oh we didn't
want this is from last year okay
oh is the calligraphy yeah yeah that's
pretty cool actually alright one should
not Chinese Lunar New Year stuff there
Oh Gangji skin apparently changes his
dragon alts to a typhoon oh so when he
like yeah when he wouldn't eat when he
does it yeah it must be all that is oh
it's like a dragon and then also his his
yell like the tiger becomes me I don't
know someone would have to actually I'd
have to listen to it okay we're gonna
we're gonna try that if are you guys
going to stream Rainbow six siege
operation outbreak when it is released
yes probably creeper stash 101 most
likely
talk about star wars over and over again
I can't really do a great job of that
you need Rob although Lando be looking
clean Lando who cares about Han I don't
remember I never have an epic how I mean
well it's like all emotes are epic so
anyone that they do whatever what's up
car Dianna Morris thanks for tuning in
for the first time come on ok equipment
equipment yeah it looks so cool dude you
are having like disgusting luck it feels
like I know it's like 20 boxes anything
you have half of the I have 1/2 of the
three or four legendary I've three widow
mercy because it's only there's only
five right so they're so far and Zarya
that's all you're missing yeah legendary
voice are you sure
pretty sure yeah I'm sure chat will
someone tell us I'm afraid I may have to
change off my scent ing skin now says
Ben I know ya know that skin is too
legit to quit
although I would have I would have it
would have been funny if they did give
him the white Power Ranger instead I
like a good skin or something no just as
his legendary just make it though like
weight White Ranger dude it was tiger
maybe they'll save that for a year the
tiger oh sorry I totally talked over all
those but whatever just be Boop's and
cur what yeah that's something they
would say back then the magistrate oh
sorry that's not McCree Oh more lycée
baby
this was when you're a kid and you kind
of know like you're not supposed to open
lycée in front of people because it's
like disrespectful so you just say like
oh I gotta go to the bathroom and then
you open your life see you're like two
bucks [ __ ] when they give it to you and
you can aren't you already know what's
in it because it's a couple of quarters
like and candy don't don't be that
person
this is why there's six new skins total
legends it's yeah so we do have half I'm
missing I knew we were missing one I
just can't
oh whoa this is a fully loaded box whoa
I mean no more skins nice yeah and I
didn't have this one before so worked
out is that the same opening animation
as last year it is yeah sure sworn he
had this I'm telling you man some of
these lines are they're just starting to
blur a little bit you it's just like you
could hear them saying that yeah yeah
yeah it was just a testament to how well
we know the characters sure
say my name for the last my OA gaba do
gob gob with a mossy god with a mossy
man yeah and then I got it pretty good
so close I'm pronouncing my name says
carry on Oh Morris I'm I try I usually
butcher and then apologize so we do hear
the mourner skins not new Omar just so
you know so we still three at it yeah
I'm reading check that the other
overwatch hat this Gangi skin holy crap
you know I'm surprised they didn't do
something I mean like granted they
probably did this instead but I'm
surprised if not doing like a Winter
Olympics kind of thing yeah I mean just
because it what Irish good considering
Winter Olympics is very soon I guess
they have to like pick some
to do because with all like the
overlapping ones it's mostly dog related
voice lines not so much Lunar New Year
gotta gotta have those new voice lines
if you guys know of emotions that we
missed or something like that or intros
tell us we've shown some as we've gotten
them I guess that's that must be the
standard victory like you know this time
is victory yeah I don't know I'm not
sure if everyone gets one no I've only
seen a few so look at my crease
highlight intro says Karthik yo yo check
it out after we just got it though the
the fire has a Wolverine highlight intro
but Korea's Wolverine Miley intro unless
he's talking about I know
Winter Olympics begins tonight says Kobe
momochi yeah hey let me go okay yeah
nailed it that's not what you're the dog
themed okay whatever I'll take your
plane don't want to complain we'll take
a check we'll take a check on McCree in
a second we did get that skin the
magistrate and then we also got this hot
I think gold hot gold chest we got we
got a fan I think no the fan ones I've
been seeing like a widow has one
didn't someone just say that right I'm
supposed to get screenshots for Chris
Pereira
Chris if you're watching this I
apologize in advance
I should tell somebody to help you out
actually crap okay we got ten more we'll
just run through the rest get just get
through it baby dupes
oh gosh Barbosa
it was Blackbeard Blackbeard I don't
know one some pirate alright sorry I'm
trying to like figure this part out it
oh she's ready to swap get on in here
cuz I'm ready behind on stuff I'm
supposed to do Sam just hop on in
any time these are the legendary and hot
okay it's oh I did boo-ki yeah I'll take
it was that part of the the blizzard
widget world yeah yeah wow I just said I
can't type on my phone
I think don't worry Sam's on her way and
there she is I'm gonna know them peace
out good luck hey Sam hello how's it
going hi so you you missed many of the
legendaries that we've already gotten
from these loop boxes I know I was
watching as my world was burning outside
all the things broke but anyway yeah so
you guys have three out of the six we I
think we have four out six now I think
the only ones I'm missing oh wait oh we
got far okay now we have five hours I
think the only one I'm missing is Aria
which is what I one of the really good
ones these are also very nice what's
your favorite of the bunch I'm really
liking macri's mmm I think his is really
cool sometimes if I'm feeling bold other
times like I I have a thing where
depending on how well I do with McCree
I'm either a McCree or I'm also I could
be a makrooh if I'm just like dying
makrooh has misses a lot of shots does
not get head shots just rolls into
things by accident I think that was my
last sometimes so like when he does
something not on purpose but yeah that's
the McRib
okay all right so sorry is the only one
I didn't get I could like have enough
gold to afford I have eleven thousand
see that's how I always feel like I
never feel bad about getting loot boxes
and overwatch because even if I don't
get what I want
by the time I've gone through my lose I
can buy one yeah so I've been doing it
go for it nice hello everybody hi hi hi
I'm seeing all the hellos a little bit
oh thank you thank you Joey
hi goob
how are you alright so we're so we have
a new arcade mode which is the capture
the flag and apparently they they
changed it quite a bit from last year to
make it more I guess balanced because
last year everyone was just picking like
Symetra and Torben just camping the
whole time yeah and it would just end in
a draw and you people couldn't get
actual wins it was so much fun though I
think that was like one of the only like
seasonal game was I kind of stayed away
from yeah what was your favorite game
mode so far for like the the seasonal
ones yeah um I really liked last year's
Christmas one the Mays Yeti hunt that
was pretty cool yeah that was a Lucille
Ball is always fun I think I hope they
bring it back for the summer the summer
games this year the summer games the
Olympics no not not the Olympics summer
yeah so like also in this patch I don't
know if you noticed but there's a couple
of I read there was a couple of quality
of life changes as well so like when
you're searching for a match it'll
actually it'll actually show you what
game you're searching for in what map
you're gonna be playing just like
because it's always been the case where
I've been I've cued up with friends and
they've just randomly picked Arcade Mode
where I was hoping they were a bit quick
play I'm just sitting there and you
don't really know until you actually get
into the match and see all these things
are different you know I mean I guess it
gives you a heads up so you know yeah
you know think about it for a minute
what happened to Tay
we got rid of him he's not coming back
hey and I swapped out okay so macri's
look at them oh my god I know I really
like them so one of the other quality of
life changes is that you can now select
your skin in the match yes I saw that
which that changes everything because
now people can color coordinate like
right in the beginning beautiful you
know what game has been doing that
forever
which one League of Legends
finally finally up-to-speed
eight-year-old game yeah no it is it is
about time it's crazy that they didn't
that wasn't a thing I know the very
beginning because I can't tell you how
many times I've started a match I've
been like you know what I would love to
do right now let's change my skin with
my skin
have a friend who has like a white one I
want to put on my white one yeah I want
to match alright so this this map is in
I think it was Thailand said alright it
was a nice breeze see what's this okay
I'm not gonna die falling into there I
didn't get to finish looking at the
patch notes but I did read it a few oh
you're just gonna go in there okay
Phill philanthropy League is I can't
disagree with you there well good that
is about right oh we got the flag so a
couple of things that have changed I
think you don't need to wait as long to
capture the flag til I pick it up yes
but in addition to some like apparently
some movement abilities will drop it
like if you're Winston and you try to if
you're Winston and you try to leap with
it it'll drop it so you gotta be careful
because stay as a team where is everyone
that gun has a red dangler
Anglet whoa it's dangling it's a bit
distracting
yes this McCree skin is pretty amusing
okay shoot a couple extra times just to
make sure balls flying in both
directions ashtray sir somewhere and
submit you're just launching orbs at us
that's uh pretty much how I feel every
game there's a tracer somewhere and
there's a orbs
okay maybe this is turning into him a
crew right here yeah what are some of
your most frustrating changes that
overwatch is recently made no I haven't
thought of anything recently like
they've all seemed pretty fair like it's
been the case where they've like uh
adjusted the character and then nerf
them right away
mm-hmm like with junk rat they did that
they they increased his like didn't they
just like Reese's damage he's like is
mine usage so they gave him like an
extra one and like reduce the cooldown
yes yes I get a thought it was it's good
for like mobility and stuff but it just
made him like way too just gave him way
too much of burst damage and so they
they they fix that which i think is fair
cuz I feel like he was a little bit too
strong
he's annoying so sure although probably
still kind of annoying
Oh God okay I'm out of here
yeah oh of course
Tracy I uh I am a I'm not a one-trick
Mercy I would never call myself that cuz
I don't only play mercy yeah a lotta
mercy
and so I was pretty excited about her
rework when they gave her the single res
and then they changed her yeah
I haven't played her since her recent
match so it's like I feel like res is
something that is just it just feels
like it's impossible to balance yeah
we're full team res I I miss it cuz
there were some moments there where it
was just like extremely gratifying
your whole team would be down yeah
moments before the objective like it
gave more like oh crap moments oh yeah
where's like nowadays if you get like a
good pic on character it's like it
doesn't even matter if they're Reza's up
right yeah I mean it would totally
change the game sometimes no oh okay
getting off the creek McCree mean go
Genji we have the the new skin for him
just so cool
hello Ahmed hello Jordan I also love
this in Amana I think Joey could say the
same
whoo caddy Anna says she is almost
unplayable with that rez but her healing
is still Opie her healing is OPI
sometimes you miss the old mercy but
sometimes you have to accept the things
you cannot change
but Oh Oh again
oh you're getting swerved
Oh
xanthan hell back okay so I guess it's
it's a little bit more frantic than last
time people aren't camping as much but
we it's still zero zero and we have
about three minutes left in this match I
was eliminated by Gd
oh boy that Genji skin no it's pretty
nice Cory according to someone in the
chat the the old also changes into a
tiger instead of a dragon I am excited
to see I'm an 80%
oh they scored dang
who it you feel like ng is one of your
strongest characters not really like
I've been playing him a lot more
recently I'm just trying to get like the
hang of his of his movement everything
but I've been really enjoying it
I'll say that much yeah he was quite
challenging okay I see a love turrets
hello Omar my name is Sam and I'm here
with Joey and we are playing overwatch
we have opened a bunch of skins a bunch
of the boxes got a bunch of skins and
Joey has died a lot you have to mention
that okay maybe we need a little bit
more I had to bring them up to speed
will help okay who's a diva right maybe
it maybe afar I'll just use all the
skins that I have right now a Farah is
it Farah
yeah Farah I said Farah okay Sammy we
got our flag being carried all the way
to the end
well then Matt see hax i my name is sam
it's nice to meet you welcome to the
stream
you know Joey I was thinking about when
we streamed together hmm you know I want
to like come up with a really cool
introduction oh my god
yeah and what way way is that cool
introduction so it was gonna be like
Resident 2d platformer maverick and bird
dad or like something we could like you
know the first part of the title is
really but it has to end with and bird
dad okay that sounds fine okay so we can
like you know work work around the first
title a little bit but diva diva is bag
Tony I will agree
was there any free items with the update
uh yeah you get one free loop box and
bird debt I don't think anybody knows
buy your birds I think a few maybe not
in the chat but you know cooks weren't
Gube has mentioned that do you guys go
to uncle fuzz on Twitter you can see see
Joey's Birds oh look at this so I guess
the Metra is still relevant in this
image when has to mention not been
relevant I mean like in competitive and
stuff I mean yeah at the very least in
captured the flag she's still still good
yeah have you been watching any of
overwatch leagues
I've watched a little bit yeah it's been
it's been pretty cool like are you
represent a guy at the very least I have
the skin for for Reinhardt nice nice
maybe I'll put it on how about you guys
in the chat anybody watching overwatch
League any feelings that you would like
to share today with us or not you don't
have to you mean see we'll see
see is there anyone asking about skins
like us when I saw someone asking
somebody asked what their favorite what
your favorite skin was in the game in
the game just overall I mean I'm not
sure if he's asking you or me so we
could both answer it's out what your
favorite skin is in the game and what
your favorite hero is my favorite hero
mmm I really like mercy a lot
she's BAE but I also really enjoy
playing Reinhardt yeah he's always fun
he's so much fun and I just I feel like
I laughed so much when I play him
there's something just this gigantic guy
swinging a huge hammer yeah I think his
his rush is like it's just so funny like
either you're gonna pin somebody in your
dick yeah I got it are you gonna die
halfway through we're gonna die halfway
through or you're gonna fall off a cliff
or someone's gonna dodge you or you're
gonna go head on into a situation you
didn't ask for it's I don't know he's
just so much fun well my favorite skin
is probably whoa mmm
that's hard I really buddy get this road
hug please
I love the redhead mercy skin where
she's like a Valkyrie it's not the
Valkyries skin it's the redhead version
of it
I'm cooked zebra or something maybe I
may be wrong on that someone's my
favorite one redhead mercy
you know I also really like cling
Luciola
yeah he's oh he's always a blast he's
always a lot of fun and recently I
actually really started liking Sombra
but she's a little bit hard you guys I
like tanks and like heels what about you
Zaria sorry as always I think she's
she's been kind of my name since like
season two so it's been a while um look
at this skin though look at this
snake Wow
I'm always impressed with the skins she
has nail polish
come on cap it ok we've scored oh no you
know what my favorite skin is actually
now I think about it it's the mercy from
what was that event with mercy
it was mercy Sombra Reinhart and
Torbjorn Sombra it was a game a special
game okay cool it was the one that had
that whole like backstory with it about
oh and tracer oh is it uprising uprising
yeah I loved the uprising event hands
down it was my favorite event they ever
put on I would love to see him do more
story based events like that yeah I
loved how they integrated it I was
addicted to uprising when it was out
it's like all I played for the entire
entirety of it oh my god uprising was so
much fun and I loved the uprising skins
and I loved mercy's uprising skin I
thought it was really looks really cool
nice go go go this is a diva outsider
Mick okay I think we should be alright
look which mercy is also really
beautiful I think I have a highlight I
was streaming and I was opening loot
boxes for the Halloween event with yeah
yeah check out which mercy and I think I
had a full freak out when I finally got
which mercy I was so happy I I loved her
I liked how they they added to him her
voice line like
because I know people are asking for it
a lot
see I have to say this is pretty
impressive Joey I see what you like her
Oh where's my teammate no she died okay
oh yeah sorry summer did not get a skin
for that you know what I said
somber when I thought of the uprising
event is because in the version of
uprising there's you know you had the
oligo jitters and then one where they
have like the storyline heroes involved
for the other version I always picked
sombre because her pack would hack all
the yeah it was so stupid it was so much
fun dang it close close Carlton banks I
feel like I've been in a game with them
you put in the good fight there in the
end
came in halfway though so
and people it looks like people are
really liking this map I think it looks
really cool my favorite is as a healer
whenever I'm playing healer when I'm the
one that gets the card
oh yeah that's it's like yes that's
right every time there is an overwatch
event I pretend to be sick so I can say
after school this is Earth stay home
from school maybe I used to do the same
thing when I was a kid I was guilty of
that for multiple games I remember one
time I got strep throat and I was
definitely really sick for a few days
yeah I really stretched it out cuz
Yoshi's Island came out and I was really
into it and so I was like I just stayed
yeah I could make it a little bit longer
see how long and then I couldn't play it
like when might you know if I went to
school I got home my dad was home he was
using the TV I couldn't you know but he
would when he was at work I could play
play games all day that's great hmm
go Widow rocky tells us go Widow we
don't yeah I I have the skin I'm not
sure how well a widow I am at we do if
you we do can always use a Symetra right
that's the meta for this I kind of want
to see that yeah you could do the
symmetric I kind of want to see new
skins and in action yeah
fine we'll see how this goes it's not go
Eric
is not gonna be pretty okay real talk I
got mercy legendary Lunar New Year skin
in first box - it's rigged yeah there's
a politesse the way of apologizing for
nerfing her maybe I mean that you know
what I'm not I'm not saying conspiracy
but maybe maybe maybe you know or they
could pull like that no the real classic
with some games is like they will with
new characters they give them or with
characters that they buff they release
new skins at the same time yeah ultimate
conspiracy it's like they're strong and
the new skin is out money's money take
it but ya know I don't think they
necessarily do that but it is weird that
you also got the mercy legendary as well
on the first box that's weird
do I need to go home and buy some loot
boxes I think so I think so am I gonna
get the mercy if I don't get the mercy
skin I'm gonna be mad at you Eric for
putting in my head that I had a had a
chance cool first kill with that not
even I okay goob I got nothing hashtag
rage where is that Farah
get him oh this is the kind of widow you
have to put up with when I put some what
okay okay
actually pretty fun I want to watch you
play more Widow no yeah yeah there you
go oh oh okay no mean zipping it onto
the ground yeah you get up there you
find some vertical space there you all
right
get him of course I can't Finch oh the
triggered someone nice okay I know he's
coming see I just play a different Widow
from everyone else
Oh God oh god I'm so nervous
good what do we need when you like
soldier but one of the only skins you
like is strike comes commander and it's
not even from an event soldier it's not
not a new skin but I think we need them
well now my I don't think I can say my
nickname for soldier on stream but if
you guys it's basic flank 76 Phil no one
what who is that that was a mercy he
really is just like FPS man yeah I mean
that's that's it's kind of what the game
needs because he's like the only one
that's like that
he's a Greek here I mean he's very hero
yeah you know solid dependable perfectly
balanced perfectly balanced boring he's
the perfect character I would say boring
no just rock it to the face
oh good guns of guns yeah I'm a soldier
it all his lines and stuff he's just
like an old cranky dude yeah I mean like
the whole been through too much dad
thing was really funny when like the
community like the fan art community
like turned him into a dad that was
really funny he's old he's he's old he's
like oh I was gonna I was gonna say
something but I might have been general
not generalizing there but like people
who still play Halo right I don't know
make sure people still do right I'm sure
people still do I mean 17 but he just
grunt a lot
ya know that I let's try to a voice line
quick stop doing push-ups
I forgot I switch my voice line in my
emote button you're the other one okay
we just got a huge self-destruct so
mercy is the hello nurse of overwatch
universe
Janice love goes diva is the Hello Kitty
bemmon okay we got team kill we can
score one my girlfriend called the
summer soldier skin dad 76 look at it
he's no he was a grill master 76 gun
alright Lucy let's do this migos he's my
dad if I was I don't know why I thought
when you said guns guns I like guns
and the big Tommy hammer Oh hammer
yeah me holy hammer hammer
alright let's uh torn in here
Chad kitty says I really want to see
Kenji or Farah alright
not Farrah I say Farrah I say all the
any any gay character that has a as a
second I will air it because I think
it's just the New Jersey like instead of
Mario it's Mary Ellen guys
Wow some stuff to store my turret
Norbert says daddy 76 please come home
alright Bastian
gosh that has got to be one of my
favorite things
hmm those headshots nice okay so it's
currently tied I'm curious to know what
they change in order to UM to prevent
draws I think they said that it was
something like they move the flags
closer to the center so it's easier to
cap go go go go oh cool dragon Rock says
I suggest you guys play yakuza 6 or
Wolfenstein to the new Colossus that's
insane to sudden death okay
I think the chat is missing daddy 76 you
want one go back to okay let's say you
can only call him but like from now on
like not just today like forever you can
only call him daddy daddy
Brian twitch thank you for coming to the
chat for the stream I didn't have any
time to tweet or anything about it
because like the scheduler that we use
for Facebook just like decided to ignite
before this just like it's called yeah
my whole computer caught fire and I was
on damage control alright so we got the
flag Zubaz weirded out we've got the
flags place up here now in the oh
goodness
people who are trashing scheme were the
only ones that say this game is boring
you know I've never heard anybody say
overwatch is boring ever I feel I've
heard people say they don't like it as
much
as like some other games because of I
don't know yeah I've never I think
there's just so much like there's a
level of detail in the game that you
don't get in a lot of other ones and
something I always really like yeah oh
boy I personally don't idea I haven't
heard anybody called the game boring but
I also have a lot of friends that just
love overwatch yeah oh my god everyone
just clumped up here
yikes okay Reinert thank you
on fire well we have their flight we
have their flag it is a giggly stream
take the flag cap it please
Bryant which I had my my hiatus from
overwatch as well but this is definitely
a good time to get back into it would
you just put it in there oh my god
I want to see more window plays though
why nobody should see them I know it's
so good Joey it's so good
interesting the person who's carrying
said no you don't have abilities when
you have the flag so you can't family
you can't do anything
Wow like you can't looks like he says
you can't even wall ride as lucio with
it so nothing to speed it up oh you're
just disabled and you just have to run
it all the way there they gave you legs
and that's it you're holding it ooh flea
salami says overwatch is boring oh I
know
oh look to each their own you know
William McBride says hey guys what did
you miss you missed a lot of loot boxes
have been opened we got five out of the
six of the new skins oh you have a loop
you've another box yeah we got a new one
for winning capture the flag well be
ready next actually no I bought I bought
number six
as are you that's right so so we have on
we have tomorrow but you did get five
out of six opening opening lists and
then we watched some of joeys sick widow
plays they were the top tier someone
else should take her arrows creme de la
creme chefs kiss mercy please
I want to see a mash-up of DPS mercy
tied with that song you got me begging
you for mercy
yeah the Duffy song oh yeah I'm pretty
sure I'm sure someone has a highlight
reel me to that but she's only shooting
people in the face
yeah no heels no buffs no Reza's
ignoring her teammates no flight just
running around
oh and he played some Genji kenji was
lit ish I'm so just I just want to get
his old and like eliminated a few people
to see here is a his new yell because
since it's Haley's it has a voice line
about a tiger I does re it was great
though a plus a plus our chance mm-hmm
golf clap played on the new map that was
fun that schooling nice finish off Moira
thank you the new McCree highlight intro
is kind of nice yeah it's really good we
agree where are all the health packs and
this is one of the challenges with new
maps have to learn where everything is
yes
also the little dangly thing I'm agree
is gone in yeah dangles around school
your see things and games and you're
like they just put that in there to
print they like but they just thought it
was cool and they could yeah well thank
you detail thank you
where is everyone everyone spread out
all right there my entire team is in
their base so that's when you go into
all chat you're like hello everyone
there's anybody there
oh I have the flag now Oh God it's kind
of right there casually picked it up by
mistake
Oh Tony thank you so much for coming to
the stream and have a nice day
William says I think I may be OPA f
believe in yourself and are those toys
behind you guys yes they are they are
their toys can you pick it up can't pick
it up
goob we always just want one more box
just one more box never enough no we
don't that's wait no we have I'm worried
time for mercy okay Rudy
no no Mercy's no I almost got my old
here so wolf all right we'll do this
first and then maybe mercy one can dream
start saying like overwatch lines like
in real life that's real things
oh no okay no he's molten cord
oh nice back here hi hoon doon how are
you hi LW hi hi hi Here I am not playing
today but perhaps I will play a game
next week oh this is all the way on
their side oh cool
Robert lion Lions Lions Leone's
as is it available on every platform yet
I think so yeah yeah I'm pretty sure
some people have said it was on though
it was all supposed to go live at 11:00
right go go go man
I'll get the hell out of there for HP
that's very close all right you good you
good you get some hit you're good
[Laughter]
[Music]
hi what is your favorite outfits nice
thanks
my favorite outfit is I had said it
earlier I really like Uprising mercy oh
my god I like the nude I love the new
hello diva skin oh the the cat one yeah
that's pretty good and I don't I don't
play diva but I do really like that skin
thank you she always gets like good one
guys she has great skins I live I love
how all fashion skins ganymede is always
a different type of bird yeah I think
that's super cute I think there's things
about all the skins that really creepy
well not all the skins but a lot of
skins have details that I really
appreciate is this competitive game play
no not quite
when is it not competitive game play
that's a real question it's a
competitive game
I take all my games seriously I mean
sometimes I just want to be like
mindless house you get good no yeah
sometimes do you want to be mindless
sometimes I just play like regular games
of my friends just for fun come on Lucy
you look good to like do that when
you're you have to just play regular
games to learn new new heroes because
you don't bring it off don't bring the
new heroes if you haven't played them
don't don't bring them into competitive
play don't do it like don't don't ever
say to yourself you know what this team
needs someone I've never played one I've
never played before where'd you go but
it's meta that's stuck behind this wall
who do you each man I'm a mercy man look
there's like so much I feel like there's
so much stigma around being a mercy man
yeah I guess there really is like look
I'm just being real I really like Ryan
her I play a lot of rain her I would say
like I mean mostly tanks like I really
like Zarya and IRISA a lot I Love Lucy
Oh I Love Lucy Oh - I like support type
characters whether it's a tank or yeah
like well where did that happen so old
it'll take that late we notice you be
notice what's your least favorite skin
my least favorite like any of the boring
ones that are just like colorways I
think like some of those are kind of
like whatever like which ones like just
the ones that are just like standard
different colorway is like yeah mercy
like just I mean well plain color swap
yeah like those are the like the the
base level ones like the really cheap
ones but like for legendaries I think Oh
they've missed the mark on some of them
where they just haven't really made them
that interesting or change them a lot
from there
like me their regular skin yes I I felt
that way about some of the Halloween
skins from last year I think like one of
one of submit resisting hello with 11
kills what ranks are you for competitive
hmm oh I think I placed into gold the
season trying to work my way up to
platinum lastly I was five points under
gold and I just never applied as any
play to get there I could have been
could have I could have been had at all
I feel like I know I think this the
situation last season was I realized
that the season was ending like the day
before it ended yeah I was like I'm so
close and then I played like three games
and didn't move at all
like literally bouncing up and down a
couple points and I was like all right
well you know that's good this could
take all night that was that I just want
look at this thing again his swords on
here this so cool Karianna says what is
our least favorite character and why hmm
least favorite
aside from Widow oh yes oh you just
because I can't play her you know I also
used to play a lot of May I don't mean
her but I by any means my May is so if
if there was a good jerk name for bad
May players that would be me I'd be like
oh sorry about that wall all the time I
know my least favorite that's hard okay
not because I think she's bad but just
because I don't feel really good playing
her or and it's not because I died with
her necessarily I just I just I'm like
frustrated onna I'm just
I just get like I don't feel like it's a
gratifying experience to play her I
really like her like she's she's so
different from all the other or most of
the other healers in that like she
doesn't she doesn't have mobility but I
think she more than makes up for it like
in her ability to heal like oh just her
offensive abilities are really nice too
yeah the skin is amazing by the way I
just have to say I've been staring at
like everything I wanted
well either that or I would have been
happy if you play mercy but look I'm
here for this for the Snipes for the the
noscopes this is not gonna no you
can't--no stay no there's only there's
only scoping actually yeah all scopes oh
nice good job I helped I huh
yeah watch this I was involved I need
that achievement someday where you get a
head shot while in the air nice as I
hate sim
Symetra and then bob says he was like
Widowmaker because I don't like snipers
I wish I could be I wish I could Snape
Ernie I don't I don't know we know when
they're releasing new heroes Joey do you
have any of the do I have any do you see
any scoops
no scoops but we can only assume that
like just based off their schedule last
year which they did three three last
year so I assume they've said that they
want to do about three every year stupid
wait no clipton wait I'm just gonna see
if I can nail him from this distance oh
crap that was not my hook
Oh yikes nope nope that's a bad place to
be where is everyone when you play
online competitively do you talk to
everybody in the game nope oh you're one
of those one of those I just do my job
that's all yeah don't yell at anyone I
do what I was meant to do I don't talk
in the games as Farah knows that I can't
hit her you know though I have had some
good experiences there have been times
where I have chosen to speak mm-hmm and
it went well
whew and for all sniper I've ever seen
ever I'm just kidding Joey people just
have to find me yeah it's all over okay
I'm going to activate well guess that's
not gonna work Bob Jones I feel you i
competitive can be the thing that
sometimes makes games less fun for some
people depends depends on the game so
people love the competition and the all
that and others just play for fun
hey you helped
I watched a contribution happen before -
I haven't
I don't think I've gotten a single
headshot which is fine I don't care
that sound you I believe that you don't
care Jenny I really don't
okay I I figured out your new
introduction for the next time we'll
shoot together hey guys I'm Sam your
host for today and i joining me is joey
best widow make your na and bird deaths
welcome
why pot from germany Howley is it on you
yeah I think I mean Holly is here and it
is early in the day
it is midday it's a it's about a lunch
time it's lunch it's lunch o'clock
Joshua used the group option on Xbox to
find decent players I have never used
the group option before do you find it
successful
cyborg manses speaking of watches 8 out
of 10 10 times going to be toxic people
telling you to change this is true
either because they you know whatever
blah blah meta meta meta or because
you're bad change of character or they
just like it was predisposition of like
oh these characters shouldn't ever be
played yeah people just got nerfed blah
blah blah or this one's a better pic
that's all that matters oh alright
that's enough of that
let's go what do we need I just say
after watching you like do amazing
things in celeste last week was
struggling with a special occasion but
like i'm being ever credible I can't
play Widowmaker for now most people can
which is why just watching good widows
is all more so oh my god the montage is
for widow are just like wow wow wow wow
wow it's like I assume a lodge is like
left left over skill from like something
like counter-strike cuz that like a lot
of my friends who play counter-strike
just love Oh what the heck they play a
lot over watching like widows one or go
twos
oh come back give him a knuckle sandwich
what though
what does he why is he here I'm not sure
why he's out in the open
oh no Samuel you cannot update that's
that sucks and we were having a little
bit problems cuz they were doing some
light maintenance these earlier on in
the stream Mike hi anvil hi hi hi hi hi
hi hi we are not taking this flag
Christian the new map and skins look so
cool I agree I want you to play the new
mercy skin new mercy yeah the one they
the one that you had we do in the next
game okay
David asked okay so I'm just getting
into the game and I can't decide if I
should try it on PC first or get a
console but you don't really have the
money for it so what do you suggest
these IPC easy that was a easy suit
because if you want to play with the
controller just get an X but just get an
Xbox controller or Microsoft or any type
of third-party controller if you feel
like you want to play it like that but
if you have a history like think about
the games you've played in the past if
you have played first-person shooters in
the past
do you like mouse and keyboard do you
like your controller you might be at a
disadvantage using a controller if you
play on PC and your plan to play it
competitive unless you're if unless you
feel like that's your comfortable place
then just play what you feel most
comfortable best yeah but yeah PC for
sure
it's not it's not worth buying a console
for when you can play it that way I'm PC
if you wish
he's cyborg alternatively I had on ps4
and PC and I ended up giving my ps4 a
copy away because I was having much more
fun on PC yes this goes into the whole
sticks versus mouse and keyboard debate
I imagine we won't get into that yeah
yeah I have nothing wrong with console
choose I just am not good at it yeah no
no I have no problem with playing
console shooters I play destiny on ps4
when it came out
and now I play destiny 2 on PC just
because I feel like I'm better at it
that way like you know it comes down to
like your comfort level and oh I'm sorry
do you sit on the couch and play games
or do you mind sitting in your desk we
can look at look at where I land here oh
wait did we oh we lost they can see it
any time David Jay any time can you show
off the genji skin yes Morgan
so just leave this can we just like
quick quickly look at the mercy again
that's my only stare at her yeah good
Ginji here mmm nice really good
the weapons especially the fancy boy
it's like sparkles look at that wait
wait turn it a little bit nope the other
way right no no the other way
yeah yeah keep going keep going keep
going work more more ready
oh wait where'd the oh oh the glare the
gloom yeah wait it's nice okay
mercy he said yeah oh look at her a
beaut she's like the feathers on her so
Buse off - oh look at those feathers
I guess I'll play her for the next one
don't do i yeah you know what I she
doesn't need that in her life if so many
heal is already so I'm just gonna go I
like her little peashooter he's pretty
good like it's got the damage if you're
accurate with it you know how it feels
so good to like kill somebody shots
Oh like I've had tracers come after me
and just like be zipping around me and
miss like bad tracers and we killed him
it feels so good to do that it's like
revenge of the healer healers revenge
support revenge oh whoa they added CTF
to this game yes that was this patch
yeah they they had it last year for the
same the same event the Lunar New Year
this this year comes with a different
map and different rules which is always
welcome I agree I don't use Kenzi either
but that is a a pretty skin fur for him
get him he's almost dead Julie oh yes I
you could technically play at that play
PC plugged into the TV with the
controller this is true this is true
[Music]
they want skins they want a little tour
towards us get toward skins toward the
skins a little bit of Moira oh that is
the other team
her one hand like really creeps me out
like the right hand oh yeah there was no
way you were the claws on the right we
are going to lose this game it's gonna
follow this yes follow this dragon I
mean in my defense we came in like
halfway through this was already over
before it started
are there any items that weren't shown
in the trailer that came empty what was
in the trailer
oh there I am they didn't show there was
only one skin that they all made it from
the trailers McCree no wait macri's and
[Music]
this is just McCree I because I know
they didn't show his yeah I don't know
if they omitted any others but yeah that
makes sense which is weird because it's
my skin yeah I really like it yeah okay
do I even have anything left
I'm sure there was plenty of like other
cosmetics like sprays and stuff yeah
nothing in here though nope let's go
take a gander all right so there was
Ginji once again wait go back around the
other way real quick look at him
beautiful beautiful saria's yeah I
really like this one
she's got her weapon which is I think it
was was it mercy Farah Zarya and Kenji
all their weapons are themed after like
zodiac animals mm-hmm so you have like
the snake for Rosaria tiger I assume for
Genji this is your dog do yeah I don't
think so I was I was thinking that um
IRISA might have got might get one but
unfortunately no when I heard it was
gonna be it you're the dog I was like
it's gonna be a good year
good that's for the best Farah one's
really good they all have like this
emblem - you had the rotating emblem
somewhere like I know her gun is right
yeah
oh she oh I just noticed the ring on her
weapon yeah so has it but that's pretty
cool
yeah her skin is really nice Mercy's
very nice
what about emoji and highlight intros oh
yeah well we'll take a look at those
after this one yeah McCree I at the very
least I know McCree has a really cool
highlight and really mercy has a high up
nice I'll introduce you I think so I
know she had one last year man she has a
new one I might be incorrect my bad guys
that might just be like very normal yeah
yeah she was the the calligraphy one yes
she like draws on the ground I remember
that that was beautiful I'm biased
everything she does is beautiful
wait no yeah let's see if I can do some
acree stuff here [ __ ] dude thank you for
coming to the stream today I hope you
have a wonderful day we'll see you next
time
sweet you ooh can't see who I'm shooting
but that's fine damage me Oh
goob I am I got a soft spot for her what
character makes you rage like playing
against yes hmm
I don't really know the thing is that I
don't really rage in the game too much
yeah this is really just like very very
calm disappointment at getting
eliminated by certain here yeah thanks
less and everybody was like how has he
maintained composure and we were like he
just has this you know yes is stillness
want to be in here how long has the
stream gone on for it started at 11:00
just after 5:00 couple out minutes after
11:00 had some server issues
Eric and I swapped it about 11:30 after
we opened some loot loot crate's boxes
blue boxes
and Joe we got all the skins there v
nice go mate that's a nice feeling good
a good May is a great man a salmon qi g
py boi-ing says Symetra makes me hey my
life like when she bounces around you oh
my god oh yeah of course I feel that
road hog is my favourite sister and Oh
according to the Assads metro is getting
a buff soon yeah that's what that won't
yeah they want to make her like more
viable in like just in the competitive
mode because basically like in
high-level play nobody really plays her
like there's there's people that do her
job a lot better or I can't imagine
exactly what they would do that they
haven't done already I can't see her
being any more offensive than she
already is
I think these voice lines about the
flags
thank you
Oh third time from that Hanzo your hat
fall off and spit on the ground yeah
adding insult to injury my my thing is
if you have a really hard time facing a
certain hero just like start playing
them so you learn well yeah that's
that's kind of the idea that I always
try to like promote just try to learn
everyone else like you can only get so
far just playing one hero all the time
right and you know what it is like you
end up discovering what their weak spots
are like if you get frustrated by the
strengths of another hero when you play
them you'll start to learn her weak
points
yeah you can start to take advantage of
that Oh everyone's gone nice nice scared
him off how was that very anticlimactic
High Noon Oh Hans oh he's doing work on
their side maybe I should get this game
since dinosaur man looks great every
time I see it it is really fun it's just
you know I was very skeptical of
overwatch when it first came out for
some reason I didn't think I was gonna
be my type of game I think they've just
like consistently like with their
consistent updates like they've shown
that they can provide like oh just like
a good world for everyone yes I didn't I
wasn't like reasons to always come back
yeah yes exactly
which I think they proved themselves for
sure do this I remember the thing that
the moment I realized that this was
gonna be a game I really liked was
actually the halt the first Halloween
event with all those skins ooh
nice nice nice go I just remember
getting really I'd played it a little
bit and I didn't think it was
necessarily great or terrible game it
was fun but I was like yeah we'll see
how long this lasts
and then that first Halloween event I
just all the sudden was like this is
cool where do you go and like the
introductions of all the new heroes have
basically felt good yeah like that was
like a scary thing we're just like how
could they make like the future heroes
are just more interesting yeah like how
are they gonna fit the new heroes into
the world that they created so here's
here's the thing Symetra chasing me this
map is so cool Joey Murphy says
it's a pretty good one no Joey also asks
do you have any golden guns and if so
which is your favorite the only golden
gun I have right now is saria's which is
really nice I really like it shady
pretty me the right decision
is everyone dead yes well no I'll just
back here boy
I don't think any characters are toxic
per se the characters themselves Oh like
unless we're getting into like a like
the personality of the characters are
toxic that would be pretty
straightforward yeah
no I don't think that like you can't
like stereotype certain play like oh
kenji players are like this yeah players
are like this
you know we're see players like this you
yeah it's always depending on the person
yeah really
please turn off all chat you don't think
any hair just toxic ever know
I'm roll Knight congratulations he just
got the news area skin and yes of
another victory did it you did it fam
I'm glad I wasn't part of this bob says
he wants Activision to make a
traditional FPS game set in the
overwatch world like how's that gonna
work I don't know I'm not sure you know
what I want I want an overwatch movie I
okay so I'm kind of like split on that
because I know that Blizzard would be
amazing they would yeah it would be
really cool they do such a good job at
like what their cinematics and
everything but there's something about
the way that they've been releasing
their shorts that I kind of actually
like in the way that they are amazing
not only like not only the shorts
themselves but kind of the way that you
get to know the characters and
everything before the shorts happened so
it makes it feel a little bit more I was
just like it hits home I think in a
better way
like the UM the last one that they did
Rhinehart's like his was really good but
it was better because there was that
mystery setup with the with Ike involved
in the first place like you see it in
its present day and you don't know
exactly what happened but there's you're
fighting it in there's like this mystery
surrounding that so when they actually
go into the the backstory behind it just
fuels oh it feels a little more special
right yeah you get that more unique you
know they get to focus on certain
characters different aspects of the
story in the lore who knows maybe once
they have like maybe once every
character has had a short yeah at that
point they will have enough backstory to
work with maybe making something more
along yeah pretty cool I think it would
be amazing to be quite honest I am I get
super tired of all of these like you
know video game turns really mediocre
movie yeah I like you know that maybe
that's another reason why I'm just kind
of like not completely on board with it
of the history of those kinds of things
every single time a video game turned
into a movie but could you imagine if
the actual like publishers of the game
were the ones in charge of making that
movie like they should be
there's I think that would be amazing it
and the more of this like what whatever
is happening with whatever out happened
to Assassin's Creed and little Tomb
Raider movies and like my goodness I
don't know if I could handle another bad
video game remake movie but I would love
to see an overwatch film that was made
by Blizzard like that would just be
perfection
maybe maybe as long as it wasn't like a
like a real-life version of overwatch
yeah really weird like doing live-action
version like something kind of cartoony
that's not gonna work
Raphael says overwatch to be a Netflix
series could be I would go like I would
love that
yeah that's I like with movies it's like
it's there's kind of like that finality
to a movie where like with 26 characters
like how are you gonna fit however many
storylines you want into like at the
most two and a half two hours two and a
half hours like there is always gonna be
people always gonna be characters that
people will just be like man why
couldn't they spend more time on and so
and so and like no one's ever happy yes
this is true
Assad yes you can change your skin
during spawn now let's put a teleporter
that is one of the things that happened
that was long overdue in my opinion
because so many other games have that
yeah already so that's actually pretty
cool now you guys can coordinate your
outfits where should I put this
teleporter fast okay okay okay what we
miss with that oh you know we always 6hp
I'll do a shield generator
I don't worry about so much over
watching anime they did that with doofus
though yeah and did you did you see that
the heroes of the storm short that they
did I did not
it looks amazing I think that might be
like one of my favorite you know I think
they outsource too but still it looks
really cool
the only time I've played heroes of the
storm was to get those special skins
there was the deepest candy yeah
and that was why I played here is the
storm I played a little bit in the
beginning I think it's from the many
years I played League of Legends here's
the storm feels like just feels weird
almost yeah it's like it's like
MobileLite yeah I don't know it's I
think that some of the characters are so
cute I love the design
but it just doesn't feel I miss item
bill Oh drop the flag Oh dinosaur man
thank you he says we are cool jewel for
these dreams and to keep it up what do
you think they will do for the two-year
anniversary hmm no cuz like they're not
they're not tied down by like any any
theme really they can make it do
whatever they want maybe in it uh maybe
an event oh they'll definitely do an
event like what they what they'll have
with it movie that's what I want
can you sure no they wouldn't do it a
short with uh with the anniversary I
don't think I don't know oh sweet you
know what anything is possible maybe
they'll give us something for free yeah
one loop box just give us one loop box
it's like rigged to have just like aw
like sprays in it yeah
can we buy loot boxes we did open a lot
of loot boxes in the beginning of the
stream I don't think we need anymore
yeah and we got we got all the new skins
so if you want to see us open a ton of
loot boxes just re-watch this from the
beginning
and oh not the very beginning but there
were some server issues in the very very
beginning right yeah so about I don't
know how many minutes in you guys are
you like like five minutes or so yeah
five minutes in you get the loot Bob
fine skins doesn't feel good as randomly
getting them or earning that is true
yeah just like having to just pop up
when you don't expect it right or
earning it for some reason like with the
heroes of the storm thing although that
was totally just to get people players
the storm I think but I mean they put
quite a few heroes from overwatch into
heroes which is interesting that they've
been able to convert them yeah properly
it's kind of cool seeing little mini
versions of them run around the map like
I played Lucy oh yeah I was like it's
kind of the same cool I like it it
translates pretty well it does yeah they
definitely had to be choosy with who
they picked for that game yes obviously
not everybody would work and there were
definitely changes that were made
so overwatch League skins what about him
I got one nice ah it's just a big ol
orange tangerine Rinehart salmon column
basketball Brian heart oh yeah let me
let me see the highlight intros for
somebody yeah forgot about them so
macri's hasn't McCree has one he throws
his pipe that's the firework vamp is
really good what a band see who else
that's me burning my bridges to my
enemies
this is this new this competitive
capture-the-flag
cool and so this takes place in not only
the the tie line map but just all the
other capture flag maps that they have
let's see I do wish there was something
year of the dog themed in here besides
the emblem but or is emblem that's
likely your dog right I think so
yeah this one ready yeah I can't see
they're all they're all there at the
animal that they are representing right
so like oh no that's a tiger yeah there
yep mm-hmm
I assume that be a snake yep and then
for mercy what did mercy
or maybe not mercy had drove out they
all had them didn't they well I think
because she doesn't have the same like
gear was like bulky yeah we need a
healer who is GameSpot's favor overwatch
league team
I can't sweet home yeah hometown right
the San Francisco that would have to be
the default answer although I'm sure
everybody has their opinions yeah where
are we going all right William McBride
thank you for joining us and I hope you
have a good night's sleep
oh boy mercy looks like the girl from
Soul Calibur there's also a few that are
alive like character skins now facility
sort of like yeah pretty close
oh no oh no you stay alive okay you got
eliminated by meatloaf
the band or the food or the no is it
isn't meatloaf just one guy oh right
pretty sure did I live my whole life in
a meatloaf was a whole band well I I I
went a long time thinking Dru Hill was
one person oh man apparently he's not
just Cisco he's all of them
I searched a meatloaf and I got a bunch
of recipes we meatloaf now boys all
right come on let's get the flag wow
you're right meatloaf is one man
I'm taking it back all this time go dude
go you have a feeling you won't ever get
any more did her live games philanthropy
I cannot speak to that haven't read
enough about about what's going on in
the DOA world
okay we're doing but I feel like if dead
or alive five was any indication there
should be more because I feel like that
game was so positively received by the
people who played in her alive don't
know but that doesn't necessarily mean
anything volleyball yeah why uh Studios
choose to make games doesn't matter how
much you love it Kingdom Hearts two it's
been a long time how many well Ellie at
the very least with Kingdom Hearts to
get all the in between games we have the
remix 0.576 and one point for some
others whoa where am I going the kingdom
2.67 twisted version I don't know I'm
just making fun of it i chain of
Memories I remember all that I played a
lot of them to a point and then I was
like what does it all mean people who
who've made the game don't even know the
story anymore yeah oh man I saw an
amazing like reddit thread it was like a
manifesto that talked about like
summarized king of King of Hearts story
from start to finish yeah and it was
just is it was it that text document
that was like this person did this to
him and who which in turn did this it
was like this long yeah it's like a
pages long of like trying to explain the
entire story from the very beginning yes
I might have seen like the first page is
ridiculous
yeah really good TL DR version it was
quite something I also saw a very
similar thing for final fantasy xiii
trilogy
which is also kind of a mess Kingdom
Hearts 720 noscope stalefish 3 7:35 / 69
days 420 shadow flip featuring Drake
that was beautiful that was beautiful
Norbert Schmidt asked if he could play
with us I don't know if we do that here
do we ever do video games um no I knew
it I knew it
so today we're not doing viewer games
but if we are gonna do them in the
future we'll probably post about it yeah
probably be like a thing that we set up
Bob Jones you know it's not about idea
but nor Richmond if you ever want to
play with I mean I have an open discord
that I use in my own stream if you have
on play with me
it's like Hema it's my my name on
Twitter and you can find all my
information there about my stream and my
discord oh man story cat videos that
sounds like a really good idea this is
gonna take us like a year to produce
that one yeah reports oh my god or any
of like the Final Fantasies that have
like multiple sequences or timelines
yeah I think this is gonna be our last
game yeah I think so I think we're well
on our way to winning this one so it'd
be good it'll be nice to know yes
because angle right here oh oh no curve
ball
nice
ooh you know I haven't played Maria and
she is so much fun yeah except one you
get eliminated by meatloaf starting to
eat most oh man or band I don't know
Norbert Schmidt is new to this channel
welcome to your very first games watch
stream it's great to have you here
hello if you haven't been here for very
long in this stream I'm sorry that we're
gonna end soon but you should come back
every time every day around this time
and we'll have a straight money through
Friday normally in the midday Oh radians
and a lunar loot box is the end there
good job we'll open them up and then I
guess maybe run through some of the
skins that people still want to see it
and then all the street yeah
every time I see you a Winston play the
game I'm just like I know this is gonna
be a lot of jumping back people around
meet little three gold medals nice you
got a card there luckily alright then
this baby up shouldn't really have much
else in here since we have most of the
stuff which I don't have
sure I'll take it instead of the can
crusher oh this was one of his other
secret friend emotes i really like that
one put his um his lunar last year's
Norbert game Spa is located in San
Francisco California USA oh my god super
adorable so again there's a mercy skin
which we saw pretty lady cool staff
gingy's of course
oh what a stud can't this is just making
me you want to play more I know look at
that sword shiny sharp dangerous pretty
got McCree here under underrated I would
say subtle but also wow look at that
look at that pipe sorry sir sorry is
strong I'm havin I go there any other
additives there sneakily protected
sneaky no not very sneaky but snakey
snakey if you will
she's even got those uh Jade rings on
there her gun goes hiss
and then who's the last one Oh widows
which beautiful I showcased very well I
think it actually that is a beautiful
skin I want to see some cosplay of that
yeah I'm sure you'll will probably be a
hit
such snipe much Wow that's how we can
sum up Mitch always can be I'm like so
tempted to go back and just make it like
a super cut and while you're so good
this is posing me Farah is very
beautiful she looks like a jade yeah her
gun though dragon tassel mm-hmm alright
and I think that's it for skins unless
I'm forgetting someone I don't think so
yep
sweet well then on that note thank you
for joining us today guys for this
overwatch dream hope you enjoy it all
the new things
mm-hmm Joey have any final thoughts uh I
really like the skins also the map the
map is really really really nice like
for them to go with the Thailand for the
first time yes good way started off I
think yes I agree
alright guys if you want to come back
and check out our streams we stream
around the same time every day around
11:00 or noon 11 ish Pacific Coast time
Monday through Friday and we'll see you
guys tomorrow
thank you for joining bye oh wait I know
it this time it's a button
you
you